Hey, I'm Jason. I'm Sean. I'm Will. They said do it quick, not like legal. Hi, I'm Jason. I'm Sean. I'm Will. And it's an all new smart list. Let's go. Let's go to all of this. Hey, do you guys ever grind your teeth? Because last night I had this pain from my jaw through my ear all the way up to my top of my head. You don't have a chew bar or a mouthpiece? You know what? That's a good idea though. I could take a chew toy from my dog. How about a bite plate? Well, you probably just use your cereal spoon. You just sleep with your cereal spoon in your mouth.
嘿，我是杰森。我是肖恩。我是威尔。他们说要快点，别像法律程序那样。嗨，我是杰森。我是肖恩。我是威尔。这是一个全新的智能列表。我们开始吧。让我们进入这一切。嘿，你们磨牙吗？因为昨晚我的下巴疼，一直延伸到耳朵，直到头顶。你没有磨牙棒或护齿套吗？你知道吗？那是个好主意。我可以拿我狗的磨牙玩具。咬合板怎么样？嗯，你可能只是用你的麦片勺。你睡觉时嘴里就含着麦片勺。
You know how much I love cereal. And I like to mix cereal. Every time he calls me, he has a bowl of cereal in his mouth. I know. And I make big industrial. I just finished off a nice big bowl of lentils. A big lentil soup. Gosh, that's delicious. Do you remember lentil soup? Yeah. What do you mean? I'm not in a fight with my body, so I eat healthy food, so I don't need to remember lentils. It was yesterday and a couple of days before that. Oh, man. Legumes. You really showed me. Yeah. Well, yeah. Your body will go into shock when you give it frosted flakes seven
你知道我有多爱麦片。而且我喜欢混合麦片。每次他给我打电话，他嘴里都有一碗麦片。我知道。而且我做得很大规模。我刚吃完一大碗扁豆。一大碗扁豆汤。天哪，太好吃了。你还记得扁豆汤吗？记得。你什么意思？我和我的身体没过不去，所以我吃健康的食物，所以我不需要记得扁豆。那是昨天和前几天的事。天哪。豆类。你真是让我大开眼界。是啊。好吧，是啊。当你一周七天给它吃磨砂片，然后又用同一把勺子给它吃点扁豆时，你的身体会休克的。
days a week and then you give it some lentils off the same spoon. You guys, I'm going to fight with my body too. That's why I'm drinking juicy juice this morning. Why are you so angry at your colon? You had to infantilize it, right? Like you just needed to have like a little kitty name on it to make it. And Will, you had a Diet Coke there, did you? Yeah. Do you know the gang down at Diet Coke? Again, I keep asking if they've got a face man or just a pitch man or a voice man because I'm ready.
你们，我也要和我的身体过不去了。这就是为什么我今天早上在喝果汁。你为什么对你的结肠这么生气？你得把它幼稚化，对吧？就像你只需要给它起个小猫的名字来让它……威尔，你那儿有健怡可乐，是吗？是啊。你认识健怡可乐那边的人吗？再说一次，我一直在问他们是否有代言人，或者只是个推销员，还是配音员，因为我已经准备好了。
I don't think they advocate drinking it at 10.03 AM West Coast time. They do like these large glass bottles of just orange liquid that I have here, which is water and electrolytes. I love those. That's why I'm 67 years old. I look like this. And I love those bottles that look like you ripped them off of an Amish farm. You know what I mean? Just to keep it rustic in Beverly Hills. I know. God damn it. What a clown show.
我不认为他们提倡在西海岸时间上午10点03分喝它。他们确实有我这里这种装橙色液体的大玻璃瓶，那是水和电解质。我喜欢那些。这就是为什么我67岁了。我看起来像这样。而且我喜欢那些看起来像是你从阿米什农场偷来的瓶子。你知道我的意思吗？只是为了在比佛利山庄保持乡村风格。我知道。该死。真是个小丑表演。
Their style inside the fridge, which I think is going too far. But yeah, there's a lot. I've seen your, your wife, but by the way, it should be noted, your wife has excellent taste. She really does. In stuff, not in dudes. Oh, right. Oh, I feel like that's a shot at me. Maybe. Let me think about it. I'm, I'm, I'm guys. I'm super excited about our guest today. You know, it's not the biggest
他们的风格在冰箱里，我觉得这有点过分了。但是，是的，有很多。我见过你的，你的妻子，顺便说一句，应该指出，你的妻子品味极佳。她确实有。在东西上，不在男人上。哦，对。哦，我觉得那是针对我说的。也许吧。让我考虑一下。我是，我是，我是伙计们。我对我们今天的嘉宾感到超级兴奋。你知道，这不是我们请过的最大的
guest we've had on, but still this person was really kind to say yes to me. And I've loved this person for a very long time. An incredible story. Actually, this person played Bobby Hopkins on the golden girls. One of my favorite characters. I'm one of my favorite sitcoms. And then get this didn't work for 20 years. And then out of nowhere wins an Oscar, right? What? We have an Oscar winner. Not since Roberto Bonini. Guys, it's George Clooney.
嘉宾，但这个人能答应我真是太好了。而且我爱这个人很久了。一个不可思议的故事。实际上，这个人曾在《黄金女郎》中饰演鲍比·霍普金斯。我最喜欢的角色之一。我最喜欢的电视情景喜剧之一。然后听着，20年没工作。然后突然之间赢得了奥斯卡奖，对吧？什么？我们有一位奥斯卡得主。自罗伯托·贝尼尼以来还没有过。伙计们，是乔治·克鲁尼。
Hang on. Come on. George. What? Did I skip anything? Did I get that right? Well, I was a little hurt that I wasn't the biggest star that you've ever seen. No, no, no, he didn't say biggest star, biggest guest. And I think Kamala Harris, you would agree has got to be right near the top, sharing the pinnacle with, with Stacey Abrams, perhaps.
等等。来吧。乔治。什么？我漏掉什么了吗？我没说错吧？嗯，我有点受伤，因为我不是你见过的最大牌的明星。不，不，不，他没说最大牌的明星，是最大的嘉宾。而且我认为卡玛拉·哈里斯，你会同意，必须排在最前面，也许与斯泰西·艾布拉姆斯共享巅峰。
Yes, I would agree that I'm not, I'm not in that league. And maybe Paul McCartney, can, can he be above your, your altitude? Well, you know, what has he really done? This is good. This is really good. I, I, that was my attempt at being sarcastic, George. Can I say something? You know, I've been listening to this podcast. Do you like to call it? He has notes. He's got notes. I wanted to do this show. I wanted to do this show because I do really enjoy it. And I have
是的，我同意我不在那个级别。也许保罗·麦卡特尼，他能超过你的，你的高度吗？嗯，你知道，他真的做了什么？这很好。这真的很好。我，我，那是我试图讽刺，乔治。我能说点什么吗？你知道，我一直在听这个播客。你喜欢叫它什么？他有笔记。他有笔记。我想做这个节目。我想做这个节目，因为我真的很喜欢它。而且我必须
to say I enjoy it mostly because I feel as if the guest really doesn't, isn't involved at all in the show. No, it doesn't matter. You don't have to do anything. There's no pre-interview. It doesn't matter who it is. Sean doesn't even have questions. No, you talk about each other. And we don't let you do any talking.
说我喜欢它主要是因为我觉得嘉宾在节目中根本没有参与。不，没关系。你什么都不用做。没有预采访。不管是谁都无所谓。肖恩甚至没有问题。不，你们谈论彼此。而且我们不让你说话。
And I enjoy it so much that I thought I'd just come on and just sit back. Yeah. Yeah. You make a really good point. And I want to get into that. But first, Sean. Yeah. What's up? So you don't have the bite plate. Exactly. You don't have the cereal spoon.
而且我非常喜欢它，以至于我想我就上来坐着就行了。是啊。是啊。你说的很有道理。我想深入探讨一下。但首先，肖恩。是啊。怎么了？所以你没有咬合板。没错。你没有麦片勺。
George. George, I'm so excited you're here hanging out with us. Yes. I'm so excited too. And thank you for taking the time. I know you're... It's fun to see you guys. It's a great delight. You know, Sean, you know, Jason and I, people will not know this. But Jason was a very big star of a show called Silver Spoons.
乔治。乔治，我很高兴你在这里和我们一起闲逛。是的。我也很兴奋。谢谢你抽出时间。我知道你……见到你们很有趣。这真是太高兴了。你知道，肖恩，你知道，杰森和我，人们不会知道这一点。但杰森曾是《银色汤匙》节目的超级明星。
Yes. And we were at Gower Studio. I was doing the Facts of Life. It was like 1985 or 86, maybe. And I'd set up a little basketball court out in the back and Jason, young Jason, very young Jason, would come out and shoot some hoops. And we would shoot around back in the... Back in a long time ago. I had a nice mullet then. Oh, you did. You were trying to bite Stamos' style. You were going for your blackie look. Well, you know, he had it down, by the way. He did.
是的。我们在高尔工作室。我在做《生活的事实》。那是1985年或86年，也许。我在后面搭了一个小篮球场，杰森，年轻的杰森，非常年轻的杰森，会出来投篮。我们在很久以前……在很久以前投篮。那时我留着漂亮的鲻鱼头。哦，你留过。你试图模仿斯塔莫斯的风格。你在追求你的布莱基造型。嗯，你知道，顺便说一句，他掌握了它。他确实掌握了。
He looked good. So, George, so you knew Jason back then. He came and he played basketball. And then he kind of, you know, he has a long career in showbiz. And then he reaches new heights later in life. And were you just as shocked as anybody to see him find success? I knew there was something hurtful at the end of it. It was pretty surprising. You know, every once in a while, you know, we'd touch base. I'd see him at an event. And I kept thinking, first of all, I think I haven't seen you in a while. And then I would think that's about right.
他看起来不错。所以，乔治，所以你那时就认识杰森了。他来打篮球。然后他有点，你知道，他在演艺圈有很长的职业生涯。然后他在晚年达到了新的高度。看到他取得成功，你和别人一样感到震惊吗？我知道最后会有一些伤人的东西。这相当令人惊讶。你知道，偶尔，你知道，我们会保持联系。我在活动中见到他。我一直想，首先，我想我有一段时间没见到你了。然后我会想那很正常。
You'd go, oh, that's why. Look at him bearing it to the walls. There's the reason. Everybody had shorted my stock and did very well. George, where are you right now, by the way? Because for some reason it's hard for my brain to accept that you live in Italy, because I prefer that you live in the same town that we do. So I can just come and go as I please. Well, I'm living in Boston as we speak. In fact, I'm looking out at the ocean right here. I'm doing, I'm directing a film in Boston right now with Ben Affleck and wonderful actors.
你会说，哦，这就是原因。看他全力以赴。这就是原因。每个人都做空了我的股票，结果做得很好。乔治，顺便问一下，你现在在哪里？因为出于某种原因，我的大脑很难接受你住在意大利，因为我更希望你住在我们住的同一个城镇。这样我就可以随心所欲地来去。嗯，我说话时住在波士顿。事实上，我正看着这里的大海。我正在，我正在波士顿导演一部电影，和本·阿弗莱克以及出色的演员们一起。
I'm so excited that you're doing more and more and more directing. Do you see that, not to get into a serious question, but do you have a sense of the ratio, how you'd love for it to go or not go? Is it all project related or? No, you know, I mean, how much are you, you're doing a lot now, right? I'd prefer to do it full time only because I'll bet like you, you, it's so complicated and challenging, more so than the acting. Maybe it's a more difficult job, I don't know, but you seem to be as comfortable with the acting as I am and was and you maybe want to take on a little bit more.
我很高兴你做了越来越多的导演工作。你觉得，不是要进入一个严肃的问题，但你对比例有感觉吗，你希望它怎么发展或者不怎么发展？这都是项目相关的吗？或者？不，你知道，我的意思是，你现在做得很多，对吧？我更愿意全职做，只是因为我敢打赌像你一样，它太复杂和具有挑战性了，比表演更甚。也许这是一份更困难的工作，我不知道，但你看起来对表演和我是，曾经是一样舒服，你可能想承担更多一点。
I think it's interesting. First of all, it is that, you know, at some point, particularly when you've done television, because when you're doing television, you're doing 22 hours a year of, you know, it's like doing 11 movies. So, you know, you're doing a lot of acting and it's fun to be involved. But in general, I, you know, about 25 years ago, I just started looking at thinking, I don't want to worry about what some casting director thinks of how I'm aging, you know, I'm going to be 60 this year and well, well, by the way, just well, not, not as well as I'd hope, but you know, the alternative is death. So I'll take it.
我觉得这很有趣。首先，它是这样的，你知道，在某个时候，特别是当你做过电视时，因为当你做电视时，你一年做22个小时的，你知道，这就像做11部电影。所以，你知道，你做了很多表演，参与其中很有趣。但总的来说，我，你知道，大约25年前，我开始看着想，我不想担心某个选角导演怎么看我的衰老，你知道，我今年要60岁了，嗯，嗯，顺便说一句，只是嗯，不，不像我希望的那样好，但你知道，另一种选择是死亡。所以我接受它。
George, let me ask you this. I want to, so, so you mentioned television and I love the way that you kind of threw that out because up until kind of the nineties, up until when you were on ER, there was, there were television actors and there were film actors. And you know, there was kind of that divide did exist. And sometimes often people made the leap, but there was that sort of, there was a kind of a television actors were often frowned upon or looked down upon. Yeah, we were at the Golden Globes. It's called the television tier in the back. Right.
乔治，让我问你这个。我想，所以，所以你提到了电视，我喜欢你那种抛出的方式，因为直到九十年代，直到你在《急诊室的故事》时，有，有电视演员和电影演员。而且你知道，那种分歧确实存在。有时人们经常跨越，但有一种，有一种电视演员经常被皱眉或看不起。是的，我们在金球奖。它被称为后面的电视区。对。
And when you get to move down to the front, you feel really privileged. Yeah, yeah. But you kind of, you threw that all away. You, you came off of ER, you went into film, you were instantly successful and did it in a way that kind of gave, I thought it was fucking rad and awesome and you don't delineate between any of it. Well, I was lucky in a way. You know, it is funny. You guys all know this, having done all of it, there is this, there's this weird pecking order that you learn the moment you get into acting into the industry where it's like the theater actors shit all over the film actors and the film actors shit all over the telly. It kind of was this, a lot
当你能搬到前面时，你会感到非常荣幸。是啊，是啊。但你那种，你把这一切都抛弃了。你，你从《急诊室的故事》出来，你进入了电影，你立刻成功了，并且以一种我认为非常酷和棒的方式做到了，你没有在其中任何一个之间划清界限。嗯，我在某种程度上很幸运。你知道，这很有趣。你们都知道这一点，做过这一切，有一种奇怪的等级制度，你在进入表演行业的那一刻就学会了，就像戏剧演员看不起电影演员，电影演员看不起电视演员。这似乎有很多
of that seems to have gone by the wayside. I think part of the streaming thing has helped in a way because there's really interesting films. Television really changed honestly with the Sopranos in terms of the kind of things you could do. You could, you know, there could be nudity and foul language and things that would, I think it's been a kind of process. Clint Eastwood came out of television. Well, you bring up a good point. If my memory is working right. I feel like you made a big declaration there when you went, oh, it was Mimi's film, wasn't it? Where you went from television into film.
似乎已经过时了。我认为流媒体的事情在某种程度上有所帮助，因为确实有有趣的电影。电视真的改变了，老实说，随着《黑道家族》在你可以做的事情方面。你可以，你知道，可以有裸露和粗俗的语言，我认为这是一个过程。克林特·伊斯特伍德是从电视出来的。嗯，你提出了一个很好的观点。如果我的记忆没出错的话。我觉得你在那里发表了一个大声明，当你去，哦，那是米米的电影，不是吗？你从电视转到电影。
Mimi leader. And the other way more recently was the reverse direction was McConaughey and Woody when they went and did True Detective. I remember that was a big shift as well. And so now everything was sort of cross pollinated. Again, I was kind of lucky because it's a really weird thing because, you know, David Caruso quit after one season of NYPD Blue and he, I think he won the Emmy that year. And it was one of those things he went off to do, wanted to do movies and, you know, and said he's leaving. And up until that point, if you wanted to leave your television series
米米·莱德。而最近另一个方向是相反的方向，是麦康纳和伍迪，当他们去拍《真探》时。我记得那也是一个巨大的转变。所以现在一切都某种程度上交叉授粉了。再说一次，我有点幸运，因为这是一件非常奇怪的事情，因为，你知道，大卫·卡鲁索在《纽约重案组》一季后退出了，他，我想他那年赢得了艾美奖。这是他去做的那些事情之一，想拍电影，你知道，并说他要离开。在那之前，如果你想离开你的电视连续剧
or get out of it or, you know, they didn't let you. I mean, you didn't go. Pierce Brosnan couldn't get out to do Bond early on. And there's tons of stories of, you know, people being sued. And then he left and it sort of kicked the door open. So the next year, ER came out. It was an even bigger hit. And so the first question I was asked every day after the show hit was, you know, are you going to leave the show, which I wasn't. I was like, no, I'm not going to leave. But I wanted to, people were offering me movies and they said, we'll work it out so you can stay on the show and do a movie. So things changed sort of drastically because they were afraid that you would leave the show, which
或者摆脱它，或者，你知道，他们不让你。我的意思是，你没走。皮尔斯·布鲁斯南早些时候无法离开去拍《邦德》。有无数的故事，你知道，人们被起诉。然后他离开了，它某种程度上踢开了门。所以第二年，《急诊室的故事》出来了。它是一个更大的热门。所以节目播出后我每天被问到的第一个问题是，你知道，你要离开节目吗，我没有。我当时想，不，我不会离开。但我想要，人们在给我提供电影，他们说，我们会解决它，这样你就可以留在节目中拍电影。所以事情发生了剧烈的变化，因为他们害怕你会离开节目，这
I had no intention of doing. Was part of the no intention of leaving fueled by a sense of having an ongoing television series is like the greatest warm blanket you could ever have as an actor that you've got a gig at least eight months of the year. And yeah, I mean, how many, like I'd done seven television series before then and 13 pilots. Yeah. And so that's such a famous story that you are that guy who did like all these pilots. So I'm doing a man.
我根本没有打算这样做。没有离开的打算是否部分源于一种感觉，即拥有一部持续的电视连续剧就像作为演员你能拥有的最温暖的毯子，你一年至少有八个月有工作。而且是啊，我的意思是，有多少，就像在那之前我做了七部电视连续剧和13个试播集。是啊。所以这是一个如此著名的故事，你是那个做了所有这些试播集的人。所以我正在做一个，伙计。
Yeah. I did show Sean. I did a show called Sunset Beat where I played a rock star at night and a cop during the day. Art imitating life. I did some shows. And here, by the way, is there is one of the way who's got the worst show? Let's hear it. Oh, I think I might take the gold on that.
是啊。我做了肖恩。我做了一个叫《日落节拍》的节目，我晚上扮演摇滚明星，白天扮演警察。艺术模仿生活。我做了一些节目。顺便说一句，这里有，谁的节目最烂？让我们听听。哦，我想我可能会拿那个的金牌。
Come on. I did a show that lasted two episodes on NBC with my buddy, Michael Malley called the Michael Malley show. And we were halfway through our seventh episode and they're like, you guys can go home. And we're like, well, we only aired two. And there was it was like literally like a Tuesday and this the morning after the second airing, they were like, we're all done here. So just come get your shit and go to Radford with your tail between your legs and you're back to that line that Warner Brothers auditioning.
来吧。我做了一个在NBC持续了两集的节目，和我哥们迈克尔·马利一起，叫《迈克尔·马利秀》。我们做到了第七集的一半，他们就像，你们可以回家了。我们就像，嗯，我们只播了两集。而且就像真的是一个星期二，第二次播出后的第二天早上，他们就像，我们在这里都做完了。所以只要来拿你的东西，夹着尾巴去雷德福，你又回到了华纳兄弟试镜的那条线。
Remember? Well, people might not know like the cruelest part of doing and the same listener might know what a pilot is. A pilot is the first episode of a series. And then based on the quality of that episode, the network decides whether there's going to be a following, you know, 21 episodes to make a full season. You know what, Jason? This represents growth for you because rarely do you do that. You take the time to do anything for anybody else. And in that moment to talk, Sean's my sister.
记得吗？嗯，人们可能不知道，做试播集最残酷的部分，同样的听众可能知道什么是试播集。试播集是系列的第一集。然后根据那一集的质量，电视网决定是否会有后续的，你知道，21集来制作一个完整的季节。你知道吗，杰森？这代表了你的成长，因为你很少这样做。你花时间为任何人做任何事。在那一刻说话，肖恩是我的妹妹。
So George, there's a running thing where we explain things for listeners who may not be on the inside. Yes, I've heard. I've heard you explain it. In fact, you're explaining to me now what I actually know. Well, we're going to add you to the runner now. So for George and for Aunt Tracy, sister Tracy. It's sister. It's sister Tracy.
所以乔治，有一个运行的事情，我们为可能不在内部的听众解释事情。是的，我听说过。我听说过你解释它。事实上，你现在正在向我解释我实际上知道的事情。好吧，我们现在要把你加到跑步者名单里。所以对于乔治和特雷西阿姨，妹妹特雷西。是妹妹。是妹妹特雷西。
I'm honored. So anyway, so the cruel part is that just to finish my long-winded story, when you go in and you read for a pilot, Tracy, you sign a document that you see on a single page, what your fees are going to be for the next five years with the 5% bumps built in. If you get this job you're about to go audition for in the next 20 seconds. So you actually see, I mean, and you're talking about hundreds of thousands of dollars to somebody who's signing that piece of paper really needs it almost by definition. And it's no leverage.
我很荣幸。所以无论如何，所以残酷的部分是，只是为了完成我冗长的故事，当你进去为试播集试读时，特雷西，你签署一份文件，你在单页上看到，你未来五年的费用将是多少，内置5%的涨幅。如果你得到了你即将在接下来的20秒内去试镜的这份工作。所以你实际上看到，我的意思是，而且你在谈论数十万美元给一个签署那张纸的人，几乎根据定义非常需要它。而且没有杠杆作用。
Like you don't need any more pressure. And there's five other guys signing the same piece of paper. Yeah. It's a lot of work. And you're looking at them like, I could fucking kill this guy. Yeah. If you had to go through that pain repeatedly, George, so that's so, you get on ER and people ask you, you're going to leave a show and they're, fuck no, I'd stay here until they
就像你不需要更多的压力。还有五个人在签同一张纸。是啊。这工作量很大。你看着他们，就像，我真他妈能杀了这家伙。是啊。如果你不得不反复经历那种痛苦，乔治，所以就是这样，你上了《急诊室的故事》，人们问你，你要离开节目，他们，他妈的不，我会留在这里直到他们
drag me out. Yeah. I mean, it was, and, and, you know, I remember the first, you know, the show, you know, we were, we were getting like 42 million people to watch the show. That's crazy. And those are numbers, you know, that they're just unheard of when we had 150 channels. Yeah, I remember Noah Wiley saying, is that good? And you go, yeah, that's pretty good.
把我拖出去。是啊。我的意思是，它是，而且，而且，你知道，我记得第一个，你知道，节目，你知道，我们，我们有大约4200万人观看这个节目。这太疯狂了。这些是数字，你知道，当我们有150个频道时，它们简直闻所未闻。是啊，我记得诺亚·怀利说，那很好吗？你说，是啊，那相当不错。
It's good. I didn't watch ER a lot when it was on first run, but my ex, Amy, whom I think you know, Amy Polar, she is a absolute ER junkie. Really? Oh my God. And so we watched every episode, every night. So I got to know you very well on your ER. My wife is watching them now and it's getting me in a lot of trouble because I've forgotten
很好。当《急诊室的故事》首播时，我没怎么看，但我的前妻艾米，我想你认识，艾米·波勒，她是绝对的《急诊室的故事》迷。真的吗？天哪。所以我们每晚都看每一集。所以我很了解你在《急诊室的故事》里的表现。我妻子现在正在看它们，这让我陷入了很多麻烦，因为我忘记了
all of the, you know, terrible things I was doing, picking up on women and things. Would it be great, would it be great if you started to notice that she started to get just a little bit starstruck around you? Like she didn't know, like, you know, when you work with some people and like you're midway through the production and you happen to watch one of the things that you've never seen that they're really famous for and then you show up to work the next day and this happened really a hundred times and I just like kind of weird around them now. It was sort of like, hey, so I saw such and such last night and oh my God, you were so
所有，你知道，我做的可怕的事情，搭讪女人之类的事情。如果当你开始注意到她开始对你有点像追星族时，那不是很好吗？就像她不知道，就像，你知道，当你和一些人一起工作，就像你生产到一半，你碰巧看了他们非常出名但你从未看过的东西之一，然后你第二天去上班，这真的发生了一百次，我现在对他们有点奇怪。就像是，嘿，所以我昨晚看了某某，哦天哪，你真是太
good. I get it. Yeah. That's not my wife. Wait, I want to ask you a question about that if it's okay, George, you know, other than the fact that your wife is gorgeous and the most perfect person on the planet, what we're, because I always, you know, we aren't like, we don't hang out every day. Like people probably think we do.
好了。我明白了。是啊。那不是我妻子。等等，如果可以的话，我想问你一个关于那个的问题，乔治，你知道，除了你妻子很漂亮并且是地球上最完美的人之外，我们是什么，因为我总是，你知道，我们不像，我们不是每天都出去玩。就像人们可能认为我们那样。
Yeah. They don't. But I always like saw you and I'm like, oh my God, this guy could probably have settled down many, many times. Like other than the fact that Amal is the perfect person for you and your children are perfect and your life is perfect now, what was the, is there reasons behind the 20 year lapse of like, oh, I don't want to go that. I don't want to go that route.
是啊。他们没有。但我总是喜欢看着你，我想，哦天哪，这家伙可能已经安定下来很多很多次了。就像除了阿迈勒是你完美的人，你的孩子很完美，你的生活现在很完美之外，是什么，20年的间隔背后有原因吗，就像，哦，我不想走那条路。我不想走那条路。
I don't want to get softball. This is a great, this is easy. And by the way, answer that quickly. Right now. What's your answer on that? Just the word. Yes. And you know, the truth was, I met this amazing woman and she took my breath away and she
我不想变得软弱。这是一个伟大的，这很容易。顺便说一句，快速回答那个。现在。你对此的回答是什么？只是那个词。是。而且你知道，事实是，我遇到了这个了不起的女人，她让我屏住呼吸，而且她
was brilliant and funny and beautiful and kind and, you know, I sort of swept off my feet. We got engaged after a few months and got married within the first year that we met. That surprised me more than probably anybody else in the world and everybody else was pretty surprised. And now babies, right? What? I got two.
才华横溢、风趣、美丽、善良，而且，你知道，我有点被迷住了。我们几个月后订婚了，在我们相遇的第一年内就结婚了。这让我比世界上任何人都更惊讶，其他人也相当惊讶。现在有孩子了，对吧？什么？我有两个。
One. How old are they? They're three and a half. They're monsters. Wait, but three and a half. That's such a fun age. Everything gets destroyed in a second. Are you, are you having, because if you're like me, you, you, you discovered the, you
一个。他们多大了？他们三岁半。他们是怪物。等等，但三岁半。那是一个非常有趣的年龄。一切都在一秒钟内被摧毁。你，你有没有，因为如果你像我一样，你，你，你发现了
discovered the first 12 months is garbage and then after 12 months, it's the part they all have been talking to you about, like, oh, having kids is the greatest thing in the world. You've only got it after 12 months and then it's just exponentially better and better and better. Well, the first 12 months, the guy has literally no business, right? They don't care about you at all. They're like mom for everything, for food, for everything.
发现了前12个月是垃圾，然后12个月后，这是他们一直在和你谈论的部分，就像，哦，有孩子是世界上最伟大的事情。你只有在12个月后才得到它，然后它只是呈指数级变得越来越好。嗯，前12个月，这家伙真的没用，对吧？他们根本不在乎你。他们就像妈妈做一切，为了食物，为了每件事。
So all you're really doing is cleaning up a lot of shit and feeling sort of useless. And then, yes, the fun starts. My son now, who every mistake he makes as a child is in trying to be funny. So every, like the other day, he literally did the peanut butter joke where he puts it on his shoe and he stands there and he goes, he starts going, pop up, pop up. And he's, I go, yeah. And he goes, you smell poo poo. And I'm like, no.
所以你真正做的只是清理很多屎，感觉有点没用。然后，是的，乐趣开始了。我儿子现在，他作为孩子犯的每一个错误都是在试图变得有趣。所以每一个，就像前几天，他真的做了花生酱笑话，他把它涂在鞋子上，他站在那里，他去，他开始去，砰，砰。他，我去，是啊。他说，你闻到臭臭了。我就像，不。
And I looked down and he looks down at his shoe and he picks up the peanut butter off of his shoe with his finger and then he eats it. Come on. That's pretty high level. And he goes, oh, and I was like, I kind of humor. I loved it. That's great. I was so proud.
我往下看，他看着他的鞋子，他用手指从鞋子上捡起花生酱，然后他吃了它。来吧。那水平相当高。他说，哦，我当时就像，我有点幽默。我喜欢它。那太棒了。我感到非常自豪。
Wait, did he pick that up? Do you think from you, or do you have him, because I would learn a lot of humor from watching television and cartoons and stuff. People say, don't let your kids watch TV. No, I taught him that. Yeah. Because that seems like a, that's a George joke right there. Yeah.
等等，他捡起来了吗？你觉得是从你那里学的，还是你有他，因为我会从看电视和卡通片之类的东西中学到很多幽默。人们说，别让你的孩子看电视。不，我教他的。是啊。因为那看起来像一个，那是一个乔治笑话。是啊。
I mean, anytime you can use Nutella, peanut butter and a nappy and crunchy, crunchy is sort of adds a little bit of like, oh, Nutella in the nappy and get them to put the nappy like halfway on and then take it off and go to mama and go, mom. And then that's hilarious. That is so on brand from what I've gleaned from you over the years. And I want to get to, because I've told this story a million times and it, and I just retell you telling it. I think I saw you tell it on Carson, I think years ago.
我的意思是，任何时候你可以使用能多益、花生酱和尿布，而且脆脆的，脆脆的某种程度上增加了一点，哦，能多益在尿布里，让他们把尿布穿上一半，然后把它脱掉，去找妈妈，去，妈妈。然后那太搞笑了。这和我多年来从你身上收集到的品牌形象非常一致。我想进入，因为我讲过这个故事一百万次，而且它，我只是重述你讲它。我想我在卡森上看到你讲过，我想是几年前。
And it was, because you know, you're very close with Richard kind. Yeah. And who's a, who might have had the pleasure. I ran into him last week. Oh, he's. Hello, Jason. Hello, Will. He's such a great guy.
而且它是，因为你知道，你和理查德·凯恩很亲近。是啊。谁是一个，谁可能有幸。我上周遇到了他。哦，他是。你好，杰森。你好，威尔。他真是个好人。
Sean, you were very good, but I was better. The guy is hilarious. I was in the big knife. I killed. But you told me a great story when you guys were roommates, would you please bore these guys? Oh my God. I do.
肖恩，你很好，但我更好。这家伙太搞笑了。我在《大刀》里。我杀了。但你讲了一个伟大的故事，当你们是室友时，请你让这些家伙无聊吗？哦天哪。我做。
Please tell the story about the cat. Well, you have to understand. We were sharing. I was living in his apartment, got through a bad breakup and I was living in his apartment and I was an unemployed actor. He was doing the Carol Burnett show, the remake of the Carol Burnett show. And I would watch Jeopardy and you know, there'd be that, you know, Richard loves, he thinks he's a genius at Jeopardy too, as you can imagine.
请讲关于猫的故事。嗯，你必须明白。我们住在一起。我住在他的公寓里，经历了一次糟糕的分手，我住在他的公寓里，我是一个失业的演员。他在做卡罗尔·伯内特秀，卡罗尔·伯内特秀的翻拍。我会看《危险边缘》，你知道，会有那个，你知道，理查德喜欢，他认为他在《危险边缘》也是天才，正如你可以想象的那样。
And so I would watch the East Coast feed and then he would come home and then I would just know all the answers for the West Coast feed and he thought, he's still to this day until he hears this, will have thought that I was the greatest Jeopardy player in the history of Jeopardy. That's fantastic. And it's all horseshit. Richard, if you're listening, fuck you. That's great.
所以我看东海岸的信号，然后他会回家，然后我就知道西海岸信号的所有答案，他以为，他直到今天听到这个，还会认为我是《危险边缘》历史上最伟大的《危险边缘》玩家。那太棒了。而且全是胡扯。理查德，如果你在听，去你的。那太棒了。
And I would be home and I had nothing to do and he had this little tiny kitten that he would sleep with on his chest and he called a kitty and he'd keep it in the apartment because we're in Hollywood, you know, over on Hayworth and he was working and I'm waiting for an audition and I go into the bathroom and there's a kitty litter box next to the toilet and it's got cat shit in it and I scoop it up and I flush it down the toilet. I'm going, I'm watching Jeopardy, I think, and Richard comes home and he goes to the bathroom, he comes out and he goes, my little kitty has not taken a shit. And I think three days and I don't say anything.
而且我会回家，我无事可做，他有这只小小的猫，他会和它一起睡在他的胸口，他叫它小猫，他会把它留在公寓里，因为我们在好莱坞，你知道，在海沃斯那边，他在工作，我在等试镜，我走进浴室，厕所旁边有一个小猫砂盆，里面有猫屎，我把它舀起来，冲进马桶。我正在，我在看《危险边缘》，我想，理查德回家了，他去浴室，他出来，他说，我的小猫没有拉屎。我想三天了，我什么也没说。
I don't know why. I just don't say anything. I just am like, ah. And the next day the cat takes a shit, I flush it down the toilet, Richard checks and it goes on for like three or four or five days. Meanwhile, you're just trying to be a good roommate, right? I'm just trying to be a friend at this point, you know, and then he takes the cat to the vet and they give him this like kitty metamucil, you know, to clean your colon, you don't understand.
我不知道为什么。我只是什么也没说。我只是像，啊。第二天猫拉屎了，我把它冲进马桶，理查德检查，这持续了三或四或五天。同时，你只是想做一个好室友，对吧？我此时只是想做一个朋友，你知道，然后他带猫去看兽医，他们给了他这种像小猫泻药的东西，你知道，清理你的结肠，你不明白。
And so now this little kitten is shitting like 15 times a day and I'm scooping, I got nothing to do. I'm reading like hard castle and McCormick auditions, you know, and I've got nothing else to do. I'm flush and Richard's checking, I don't, he flips a cat on its back and he's like, feel his stomach. Does it feel tight to you? And I'm like, that feels kind of tight to me.
所以现在这只小猫一天拉屎15次，我在舀，我无事可做。我在读像《哈德卡斯尔和麦考密克》的试镜，你知道，我没别的事可做。我冲水，理查德检查，我不，他把猫翻过来，他就像，摸摸他的肚子。你觉得紧吗？我就像，我觉得那对我来说有点紧。
Again, I have no idea why it's just funny. And then I scoop up some cats, I don't know, after a couple of weeks and then the light bulb, you know, goes off and I realized what I must do, which is take a shit in the cat box. Now there is this moment, John, when I'm squatted down over a cat box. Really? Yeah. Mom and dad were right.
再说一次，我不知道为什么这只是有趣。然后我舀了一些猫，我不知道，几周后，灯泡，你知道，熄灭了，我意识到我必须做什么，那就是在猫砂盆里拉屎。现在有这个时刻，约翰，当我蹲在猫砂盆上时。真的吗？是啊。爸爸妈妈是对的。
I should have been a lawyer. Yeah. Exactly. I love the moment that it occurs to you. Oh yeah. You're just like, oh, it's funny. It's good. I'm not sure it's, I want to be remembered, but it's good.
我应该成为一名律师。是啊。没错。我喜欢它发生在你身上的那一刻。哦，是的。你只是像，哦，这很有趣。这很好。我不确定它，我想被记住，但它很好。
What was the reaction? So I went, you know, and I, when I'm watching Jeopardy, Richard comes home, we're talking for a minute, he goes in the bathroom, he's in there for like a minute and I don't hear anything. And then all of a sudden I hear, oh my God, oh my God, get it. And he comes running out and he goes, you're not going to, you have to come see this. You know, the cat, the cat is like six inches long, I mean, the tiny cat, everything bad about it.
反应是什么？所以我去了，你知道，而且我，当我在看《危险边缘》时，理查德回家了，我们谈了一会儿，他走进浴室，他在里面待了一分钟，我什么也没听到。然后突然我听到，哦天哪，哦天哪，拿走它。他跑出来，他说，你不会，你必须来看看这个。你知道，猫，猫有六英寸长，我的意思是，小猫，关于它的一切坏事。
And literally I come in and I just, tears coming down my eyes, I'm laughing to it. And slowly he figures it out and over a whole, it's this long thing where he realizes that I've been shoveling to catch it out and all, and he gets madder and madder and madder. And finally he's like, I understand, Jeopard, defecation doesn't make me laugh. He's just screaming at me. I really respect that kind of commitment to that bit over weeks, the slow burn of it fucking, I get it. Well, I did one where I found a painting that someone threw away, was sitting outside in
而且我真的进去了，我只是，眼泪从我眼里流下来，我对着它笑。慢慢地他弄明白了，经过整个，这是一个很长的事情，他意识到我一直在铲猫屎，而且他变得越来越生气。最后他就像，我明白，危险边缘，排便并不能让我笑。他只是对我尖叫。我真的很尊重那种对那个位持续几周的承诺，那种慢慢燃烧的，他妈的，我明白了。嗯，我做了一个，我发现了一幅别人扔掉的画，坐在外面
the garbage. I took it home, put it in my closet, got some paint, acrylic paint, and painted my name to it. I bought an easel and paints, I set it up in my living room and Richard would come over and go, you want to play golf, I can't, I can't, I got art class. And then I would go to those little, those, those flea markets and I'd buy paintings for like $12, they were good and I'd hang them up on the easel and Richard would come in and go, this is unbelievable.
垃圾里。我把它带回家，放在我的衣柜里，买了一些颜料，丙烯颜料，把我的名字画在上面。我买了一个画架和颜料，我把它放在我的客厅里，理查德会过来，说，你想打高尔夫球，我不能，我不能，我有艺术课。然后我会去那些小，那些，那些跳蚤市场，我会花12美元买画，它们很好，我会把它们挂在画架上，理查德会进来，说，这简直不可思议。
And the painting I took from the garbage is six feet by three feet of a naked woman. In the worst, it's in aqua and pink, it's the worst painting you've ever seen in life. And after a year of like him, you know, I made him stop at art supply stores with me to feel brushes and palette knives and he kept saying, this is just amazing what you're doing. And he's seen all these other paintings that are pretty decent and he's going, it's really amazing. And finally I go for his 40th birthday, I said, Richard, you've been so supportive.
而且我从垃圾里拿的那幅画是六英尺乘三英尺的裸女。在最坏的情况下，它是水绿色和粉红色的，这是你一生中见过的最糟糕的画。一年后，他，你知道，我让他和我一起停在艺术用品店摸刷子和调色刀，他一直说，你做的这真是太神奇了。而且他看到了所有其他相当不错的画，他去，你做的这真是太神奇了。最后我为他的40岁生日，我说，理查德，你一直这么支持。
You know, my art teacher thinks this is the best thing I've ever done and I want you to have it. And it looked great hanging up on your one bedroom wall in the living room and he rips his thing open and he's like, it's great, it's just great. It's beautiful. And I said, it was look good over your couch. And for two years, everyone knew except Richard that I'd taken out of the garbage. So everyone would come into his house and compliment him on his painting and I'm sure
你知道，我的艺术老师认为这是我做过的最好的事情，我想让你拥有它。它挂在你的一居室客厅墙上看起来很棒，他撕开了他的东西，他就像，太棒了，太棒了。它很美。我说，它在你的沙发上看起来不错。两年里，除了理查德，每个人都知道我是从垃圾里拿出来的。所以每个人都会走进他的房子，称赞他的画，我肯定
you were there. And just go, it's a great painting. And finally I did, I think the Tonight Show told the story and then said, you know, and I came home and said, Richard, you should, you should watch the Tonight Show and I got the call. I didn't, I, what's wrong with you? That is so funny. And doing the bit like that also telling him through the Tonight Show, then you told the
你在那里。只是去，这是一幅伟大的画。最后我做了，我想今夜秀讲了这个故事，然后说，你知道，我回家说，理查德，你应该，你应该看今夜秀，我接到了电话。我没有，我，你怎么了？那太搞笑了。而且做那样的位，也通过今夜秀告诉他，然后你讲了
other one on the Tonight Show. And then didn't you one time, Jillianne Marguerite, didn't you, she asked you for stories and you stole her story and told it the night before she was going to be on, do you remember that? I told, I can't, it was something horrible where I, oh, I told her a story that happened to my mom. Yeah. And then I told her to tell the story and then I had, I had like my mom and her both
另一个在今夜秀上。然后你不是有一次，吉莉安·玛格丽特，不是吗，她向你要故事，你偷了她的故事，在她要上节目的前一天晚上讲了它，你记得吗？我讲了，我不能，那是某种可怕的事情，我，哦，我讲了一个发生在我妈妈身上的故事。是啊。然后我告诉她讲这个故事，然后我有，我有像我妈妈和她都在
telling the story, like in her car back and forth, like tell it as if it's your own. And then they revealed it on the show after she told the story. I think maybe it was Leno and said, yeah, it's funny you should say that because here we have, and they put up the video and you totally set her up. That's so funny. Jillianne had, had my head on a pike for about a year for that one. So I, I learned my lesson on trying to be funny at the expense of your costar. God damn, that makes me laugh.
讲这个故事，就像在她的车里来回，就像把它当作你自己的讲一样。然后他们在她讲完故事后在节目上揭露了它。我想也许是雷诺，说，是啊，你这么说很有趣，因为在这里我们有，他们放了视频，你完全陷害了她。那太搞笑了。吉莉安因为那个让我头疼了大约一年。所以我，我吸取了教训，不要以牺牲你的联合主演为代价来变得有趣。该死，这让我笑了。
I want to get back to your life, George, because, okay, it's interesting and I love you and you're fascinating. Go grandma. Good. Here we go. No, I want to know, by the way, sidebar, my sister, I told, and I didn't tell Will and Jason this, I think for every guest that I bring on, like George today, I asked my sister from Wisconsin who we kind of, you know, break things down for so she understands.
我想回到你的生活，乔治，因为，好吧，这很有趣，我爱你，你很迷人。去吧，奶奶。好。我们开始吧。不，我想知道，顺便说一句，旁白，我的妹妹，我告诉了，而且我没告诉威尔和杰森这个，我想对于我请来的每一位嘉宾，就像今天的乔治，我问我来自威斯康星州的妹妹，我们某种程度上，你知道，分解事情，这样她就明白了。
I asked her to send in a question for George today and whenever I have somebody, I think that'd be kind of fun. A new element. Sure. My sister Tracy in Wisconsin, she asks, quote, texted this to me yesterday, do it in a Wisconsin accent, please. Okay. Well, it's different than Chicago.
我让她为今天的乔治寄来一个问题，每当我有人时，我想那会很有趣。一个新元素。当然。我在威斯康星州的妹妹特雷西，她问，引用，昨天给我发短信，请用威斯康星口音。好的。嗯，它和芝加哥不同。
Hey, George. Like, like I want to know what leading lady wasn't in like a joking mood and he got annoyed with them. Maybe they were having an off day and didn't think any of your antics were funny, George. Oh, so she just wants dirt. She wants dirt. You're going to have to apologize for her. Who's grumpy.
嘿，乔治。就像，就像我想知道哪个女主角不是在开玩笑的心情，他被她们惹恼了。也许她们那天状态不好，觉得你的任何滑稽动作都不好笑，乔治。哦，所以她只是想要脏东西。她想要脏东西。你得为她道歉。谁脾气暴躁。
She wants to know who's grumpy. No, no. Exactly. All right. We'll skip that. Because, you know, I'm not, I, in general, didn't play horrible pranks on anyone who I was actually going to do a love scene with because that always ends poorly. Yeah.
她想知道谁脾气暴躁。不，不。没错。好吧。我们跳过那个。因为，你知道，我不是，我，总的来说，没有对任何我实际上要拍爱情戏的人开可怕的恶作剧，因为那总是以糟糕告终。是啊。
You know, almost always. Right. Did you ever hear that, that, that saying right before a love scene, I can't remember whose story it is. It's a famous story. And they said to the actress, the guy said to the actress, I apologize if I get hard and I apologize if I don't. Yeah, exactly.
你知道，几乎总是。对。你有没有听过那个，那个，那个说法，在爱情戏之前，我不记得是谁的故事了。这是一个著名的故事。他们对女演员说，那家伙对女演员说，如果我硬了，我道歉，如果我不硬，我也道歉。是啊，没错。
Yeah. I think it was probably like David Niven who always had the great quotes. David Niven at the Oscars when the guy was streaking, do you remember that guy was streaking and Niven just turned to the camera and said, it's amazing that the guys, you know, the greatest moment of this man's life is, you know, by taking off his clothes and showing the world his shortcomings. Just like that. Right.
是啊。我想那可能是像大卫·尼文那样总是说出伟大名言的人。大卫·尼文在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上，当那家伙在裸奔时，你记得那家伙在裸奔，尼文只是转向镜头说，令人惊奇的是，伙计们，你知道，这个男人一生中最伟大的时刻是，你知道，通过脱掉衣服向世界展示他的缺点。就像那样。对。
Like it was like that. Yeah. I was going to streak. I rehearsed it. I was going to streak the year that Franco and Hathaway hosted and I went down and I knew those guys, you know, Bruce Cohn and his partner there were producing. And so I went and I, ABC said, well, you got to wear flash colored underwear if you're going to go across.
就像那样。是啊。我本来要裸奔的。我排练过。我本来要在弗兰科和海瑟薇主持的那一年裸奔，我下去了，我知道那些家伙，你知道，布鲁斯·科恩和他的合伙人在那里制作。所以我去了，我，ABC说，嗯，如果你要穿过，你必须穿闪光色的内衣。
And I said, well, I can't. That's not the, then it won't be as funny. I got to go and be, be holding it. Otherwise there's no point doing it. Like then it's just, it's phony. And I wanted to do this bit where I go across, I was going to do this bit where I go across and then try to go up the other side and then slowly creep back and say that the door was locked and sorry about that.
我说，嗯，我不能。那不是，那样就不会那么有趣了。我必须去，并且，拿着它。否则做它就没有意义。就像那样只是，它是虚假的。我想做这个位，我穿过，我本来要做这个位，我穿过，然后试图从另一边上去，然后慢慢爬回来，说门锁了，对此感到抱歉。
Right. So I rehearsed it. It was great. And, and then ABC was like, and I wasn't wearing underwear and I was just holding all my, all my meats and cheeses and I come, coming across and they go, um, and then ABC was, I see them huddling in the audience and they come up and they're like, yeah, we're not, you're not doing that. I'm like, what?
对。所以我排练了。这很棒。而且，而且ABC就像，而且我没穿内衣，我只是拿着我所有的，我所有的肉和奶酪，我过来，过来，他们去，嗯，然后ABC是，我看到他们在观众中挤在一起，他们上来，他们就像，是啊，我们不，你不能那样做。我就像，什么？
And they're like, no, we're not running the risk of, no, that's, thank you. You just, do you still get paid? I still got my sag. Yeah, it was great. And I've, I filled some seats on the night and it was great. Yeah. That's good job. Yeah.
他们就像，不，我们不冒风险，不，那是，谢谢。你只是，你还有报酬吗？我还有我的演员工会。是啊，这很棒。而且我，那天晚上填补了一些座位，这很棒。是啊。那好工作。是啊。
The minute someone else wins, you've got to sit right down. I want to ask some more father children questions because that's where you are in your life now. And I think. Yes, I am. So with children in your life who are gorgeous and amazing and obviously with age, a shift comes where, you know, things you deemed important before your priority list completely changes.
一旦别人赢了，你就得坐下来。我想问一些关于父亲和孩子的问题，因为这就是你现在的人生阶段。我想是的。是的，我是。所以，当你生命中有了那些可爱又了不起的孩子，随着年龄增长，自然会发生转变，你知道，以前你认为重要的事，你的优先级列表会彻底改变。
So what are some of those things that you kind of pushed down the list after meeting a mom and having a family because, because all we have is time. And so now that's compromised when you are away for four to six months, like you are in Boston right now. Well, my kids and wife are here. Okay. Next question. Yeah.
那么，在遇到妻子并组建家庭后，有哪些事情是你从优先级列表中剔除的呢？因为我们拥有的只有时间。当你像现在在波士顿这样，一离开就是四到六个月时，时间就会变得很紧张。好吧，我的孩子和妻子都在这儿。好的，下一个问题。是的。
So that is your question. Next, Tracy. Do you have any more questions? I will say this, you know, there is a funny thing that happens and, you know, I'm late to the game. Tony Randall having children at, you know, 59 and I got three year olds. But it's what everyone else knows, which is that all the things that seemed important aren't, you know, they really aren't.
所以这就是你的问题。下一个，特雷西。你还有其他问题吗？我会这么说，你知道，发生了一件有趣的事，而且，我入行比较晚。托尼·兰德尔在59岁时有了孩子，而我有三岁的孩子。但这是每个人都知道的，那就是所有曾经看起来很重要的事，其实并不重要，真的不重要。
And it's hard to imagine them not being important before the kids showed up, or before my wife showed up, quite honestly. There was, there was so many other things that I was concerned with that you're concerned with making a living when you first start out as an actor. All you want to do is make a fucking living. You don't want to write weight tables or, you know, sell insurance door to door, which I did. You just want to work and you want to have a living.
很难想象在孩子出现之前，或者在我妻子出现之前，它们怎么会显得那么重要，老实说。那时候我关心的事情太多了，当你刚开始做演员时，你只关心如何谋生。你只想赚点该死的钱。你不想去端盘子，或者挨家挨户卖保险，这些我都干过。你只是想工作，想维持生计。
And then you want to have some sort of career at some point. And then you want to have some acknowledgement of your work and some, all these things are so important at the time. And then someone like a mall walks into your life, these kids show up magically and everything changes. And all of a sudden, none of that really, you look back and you kind of was such a mad race to, to something that, you know, doesn't give you any of the, you know, it's amazing when things are great, but it comes and goes very quickly.
然后你希望在某个时候能有某种事业。然后你希望自己的工作得到认可，所有这些在当时看起来都非常重要。然后像阿迈勒这样的人走进你的生活，这些孩子奇迹般地出现，一切都变了。突然之间，回首往事，你会发现那是一场疯狂的竞赛，去追逐一些并不能给你带来任何东西的东西。你知道，事情顺利时固然很棒，但它来得快去得也快。
And, you know, you go home and there's these knuckleheads there and it's changes everything. And do you feel there's pressure about like, you know, they're growing up with you as a father and her as a mother and, and that, that you have a legacy and so how do you handle that? Well, I worry about this. I will say this, you know, all kidding aside, I do worry about the idea, you know, I was friends with Gregory Peck, I was friends with Paul Newman and, you know, they had sons who lost their lives, you know, quite honestly, from trying to live probably under the pressure
然后，你知道，你回到家，看到这些小捣蛋鬼，一切都改变了。你是否感到压力，比如，他们是在你作为父亲、她作为母亲的环境下长大的，你有一种传承，你是如何处理这个问题的？嗯，我确实担心这个。我会这么说，撇开玩笑不谈，我确实担心这个想法。你知道，我和格雷戈里·派克是朋友，我和保罗·纽曼是朋友，你知道，他们的儿子失去了生命，老实说，很可能是因为试图活在拥有一个名人父亲的压力之下。
of having, you know, someone famous as their father. I think there's an advantage for me, I'm a lot older than they were. My son isn't ever going to feel competitive with me. I'll be gumming my bread by the time they could feel competitive, right? So I think that that's, that kind of goes out the window a little bit, you know, my wife is such an accomplished human being on so many levels and she is so the work she does and how hard she works at it, you know, it'll always be something that will be difficult for either of our kids to live up to is, you know, in a much more important way.
我认为对我来说有一个优势，我比他们大得多。我的儿子永远不会觉得和我存在竞争关系。等他们觉得有竞争感的时候，我估计牙都掉光了，对吧？所以我认为这一点稍微好一点。你知道，我的妻子在很多层面上都是一位非常有成就的人，她所做的工作以及她为之付出的努力，你知道，这对我们的任何一个孩子来说，想要达到她的高度都是困难的，这在更重要的意义上是这样。
But you know, as you guys do, you have kids, you understand this, it's the same thing. It's our job to make sure that they care about people, that they challenge people in power and look out for people who don't have power. Those are kind of the things I was raised with and believe in. Have you enjoyed what being a husband and being a father has done to your instincts, either premeditated or even on the fly with what you do as an actor or director, your whole sensibility and perception? Let me, let me spin it around.
但你知道，正如你们一样，你们有孩子，你们明白这一点，道理是一样的。我们的工作是确保他们关心他人，挑战当权者，并照顾那些没有权力的人。这些是我从小受到的教育，也是我所信仰的。你是否享受作为丈夫和父亲对你直觉的影响，无论是预谋的还是即兴的，在你作为演员或导演的工作中，以及你的整个感官和认知？让我，让我换个角度问。
And to change things for you guys. It did for me. Yeah. I, I, things got, things got more subtle, more sort of surgical and in my, my taste in, in performance, the things I choose to sort of frame up and try to amplify as a director. I just, I'm sort of tuned into a different frequency. I don't know if it's a better one or a worse one, but different things like I cry watching commercials now.
这对你们来说改变了什么？对我来说确实改变了。是的，事情变得更微妙了，在我的表演品味上，在我作为导演选择去构图和放大的事物上，变得更像外科手术般精准。我只是调整到了不同的频率。我不知道这是更好还是更坏，但确实不同了。比如我现在看广告都会哭。
Never used to do that. And there, you know, there's a whole side of me that is much, much softer now. I cry watching Batman and Robin and Jason trust, but it's funny how Jason, he takes that question of like, yeah, and how it applies to him as an actor and a director, not as a human being, like a fucking robot and, you know, because he has, there is no inner life when you scratch the surface, it's more surface, but here I will say this, yeah, it's totally for me, I will say as a human being, thank you, George, talking to another human being, it's completely shifted everything.
以前从不这样。而且，你知道，我身上有一整面现在变得柔软得多了。我看《蝙蝠侠与罗宾》和《杰森·特鲁斯特》都会哭，但有趣的是，杰森他接受了那个问题，比如，是的，这如何应用在他作为演员和导演身上，而不是作为一个人类，像个该死的机器人，你知道，因为他，当你触及表面时，他没有内心生活，更多是表面，但在这里我要说，是的，对我来说，作为一个人类，谢谢你，乔治，和另一个人交谈，这彻底改变了一切。
Yeah. Like you said, it, it, it, you re-prioritize, it's a brand new perspective, the perspective that I had for leading up to my first son at 38 completely shifted. And what I do, what my priorities are, whatever it is, does it fit my life? And by life, I mean, does it fit my kid's life? And so I find myself, I probably sold myself short a lot professionally because I tried to do everything I could for my kids. And I don't know if that's smart or at the end of the day, somebody's going to say you
是的。就像你说的，你重新调整了优先级，这是一个全新的视角，我在38岁生第一个儿子之前的视角完全改变了。我所做的，我的优先级是什么，无论是什么，它适合我的生活吗？我所说的生活，是指它适合我孩子的生活吗？所以我发现，我在职业上可能经常委屈自己，因为我试图为孩子们做我能做的一切。我不知道这是否明智，或者到最后，会不会有人说你
should have been more selfish, I don't know. But it's just the way I did it. Here's the funniest part of that. I mean, and I know what you're saying, but there's, I don't think anyone is ever going to say at the end of the day, God, I wish we'd done two more interesting films rather than God, I'm, I'm really glad I spent this time with my kids or did this with my kids or that's, I think the part of the lesson that took me a long time to learn and having children has taught me, which is, and the pandemic is sort of teaching us all too, which
应该更自私一点，我不知道。但这只是我做事的方式。这是其中最有趣的部分。我是说，我知道你在说什么，但我认为到最后，没有人会说，天哪，我真希望我多拍了两部有趣的电影，而不是说，天哪，我真高兴我花时间陪了我的孩子，或者和孩子们一起做了这些事。我认为这是我花了好长时间才学到的教训，而有了孩子教会了我这一点，而且疫情也在某种程度上教会了我们所有人，那就是
is, you know, we're all learning how deeply connected we need to be and how important it is that we have other things besides our work, because, you know, we know too many people who have been immensely successful in our industry. I mean, all of us have worked with major stars who are no longer stars, you know, shit goes away. Things change. The rules change. But it's, if you have this core, this family, these people that matter to you, then, you
我们都在学习我们需要建立多么深层的联系，以及除了工作之外拥有其他东西是多么重要，因为，你知道，我们认识太多在这一行极其成功的人。我是说，我们所有人都和那些不再是明星的大明星合作过，你知道，狗屁东西都会消失。事情会变。规则会变。但如果你有这个核心，这个家庭，这些对你重要的人，那么，你
know, you can handle anything. Yeah. Yeah. And I see Jason, all joking aside, I mean, you know, I gave Jason shit the other day, I passed him on sunset, he was dropped and he's driving his Hyundai Palisades, not as a plug, Jason. It's a great car. Great car.
知道，你可以应对任何事情。是的。是的，我看到杰森，撇开玩笑不谈，我是说，你知道，我前几天还拿杰森开玩笑，我在日落大道上经过他，他正在开车，他开着他的现代帕里斯帝，这不是广告，杰森。那是一辆好车。好车。
Got a full down seat in the back. And I see him and he's dropping maple off at a friend's house, you know, and like those are the things, we've become, it's so funny, 20 years ago, Jason and I would have been like, look at that clown driving around in the thing ticket. And now we're, I'm passing him and I've just dropped my kids and he's dropping his daughter at the table. That's what I was doing. By the way, when you guys were doing that, I was passing you calling you clowns.
后座有折叠座椅。我看到他，他正送枫叶去朋友家，你知道，就像那些事情，我们变得，太搞笑了，20年前，杰森和我可能会说，看那个开着那玩意儿的小丑。而现在我们，我经过他，我刚送完我的孩子，他正在送他的女儿去桌子那边。我当时就是这么做的。顺便说一句，当你们做那些事的时候，我经过你们，叫你们小丑。
Yeah. Exactly. I was like, look at those fucking clowns. I'm living a life. What are you? Well now I'm literally like behind you cleaning up, you know, shit and washing, you know, everything. I find myself, you know, even whether you have kids or you're just in love, thinking
是的。完全正确。我当时想，看那些该死的小丑。我正在过生活。你们是什么？好吧，现在我真的像是在你身后清理，你知道，屎尿，洗，你知道，所有东西。我发现自己，你知道，无论你是否有孩子，或者你只是在恋爱中，都在更多地思考
about mortality more and also getting older. And then, you know, we just had this incident with Tiger in town and it made me think about you, George, about your accent. I've never talked to you about it and I didn't do any reading about it when it did happen aside from like, oh God, I hope he's all right. I didn't want to, you know, comb through it and stuff. But what was, and I don't mean to ask you to tell stories, I'll bet you told a bunch of when it actually happened, but did the Tiger incident bring back some of those memories
死亡，以及变老。然后，你知道，我们刚刚在城里发生了老虎的那件事，它让我想到了你，乔治，关于你的事故。我从来没和你谈过，当它发生时，我也没有读过任何相关的东西，除了，哦天哪，我希望他没事。我不想，你知道，去翻找它之类的。但是，我不是要让你讲故事，我敢打赌当它真正发生时你已经讲过很多次了，但是老虎的事故是否带回了一些那些记忆
for you with respect to your mortality? Now that you've got a family too, that there's an added thing to all of that. You're talking about Tiger Woods accident in his car, like quite a while ago. And George had an accident in Italy, right? I think Tracy saw that in the news. Oh, Sean. Tracy's got that. Yeah, Tracy's got that.
关于你的死亡？现在你也有了家庭，所有这些都增加了一层东西。你说的是泰格·伍兹的车祸，那是很久以前的事了。乔治在意大利也出了事故，对吧？我想特雷西在新闻里看到了。哦，肖恩。特雷西看到了。是的，特雷西看到了。
Thanks for specifying which Tiger we're talking about. Well, because we don't know when this is going to air and it's going to be a while later. Right, and another Tiger might become, yeah, famous. Well, look, I will say this. I've been in a couple of funky situations before where I kind of thought it was going to be lights out a couple of times in South Sudan where I thought that, but I didn't have a family and kids and things.
谢谢你明确我们说的是哪个老虎。嗯，因为我们不知道这什么时候播出，而且会是很久以后。对，而且另一个老虎可能会变得，是的，出名。好吧，看，我会这么说。我以前经历过几次古怪的情况，有几次我以为要完蛋了，在南苏丹有几次我以为是那样，但我当时没有家庭和孩子之类的。
Look, I hit a guy at 70 miles an hour on a motorcycle and I was launched and knocked out of my shoes and hit the ground and I broke his windshield in with my helmet and then went flipping up in the air. And I was fairly sure because I'd been riding for 40 years. I was fairly sure I knew what that meant, which was probably that I broke on my neck. And I read that you landed literally on your knees in your hands or something like that? I land on my hands and knees when I finally hit the ground. You can actually watch it.
看，我骑摩托车以70英里的时速撞上了一个人，我被弹飞了，鞋子都撞掉了，撞到了地上，我用头盔撞碎了他的挡风玻璃，然后飞到了空中。因为我骑了40年车，我很确定我知道这意味着什么，那很可能意味着我摔断了脖子。我读到你落地时真的是跪在地上，手撑着地，之类的？我最终撞到地面时是手和膝盖着地。你实际上可以看那个视频。
There's CCTV footage of it and you can see me going flipping through the air. And it was just luck. If I'd landed on any other direction, I would have been definitely dead. So I remember this about it, which is an interesting thing. I'm a pretty optimistic guy and I actually, I look at the world in a fairly, I always think the best of us. But there was this moment when I hit the ground and Grant, my one of my closest, maybe my closest friend and partner.
有监控录像，你可以看到我飞在空中。那纯粹是运气。如果我朝任何其他方向落地，我肯定死定了。所以我记得关于这件事的一点，这是一件有趣的事。我是一个相当乐观的人，我实际上，我以一种相当，我总是往好处想。但当我撞到地面时，格兰特，我最亲密的朋友之一，也许是我最亲密的朋友和合伙人。
The great and creative Grant Hesloff? Yeah, Grant Hesloff. He was in the motorcycle ahead of me and he came running back and he's holding me. I'm only in on the ground and they got glass in my mouth. I thought it was my teeth. It was a windshield glass in my mouth and I really thought this was it. And all the people that got out stood over me. And once they realized it was me, pulled out their cameras and started taking pictures.
伟大的创意人格兰特·赫斯洛夫？是的，格兰特·赫斯洛夫。他骑着摩托车在我前面，他跑回来抱着我。我躺在地上，嘴里有玻璃。我以为是我的牙齿。那是挡风玻璃的玻璃在我嘴里，我真的以为这就是终点了。所有下车的人都站在我上方。一旦他们意识到是我，就掏出相机开始拍照。
And I'll remember that forever because I always think that moment that was probably going to be your last was somebody's entertainment. And it doesn't make me bitter. It just changes my perception of why, is it that important that I have to please everybody? So that thing I'm just going, okay, I get it, fair enough, if that's how it is, I thought it was a little more than that. But you got to take care of you first and foremost at all times. So it's kind of, yeah?
我会永远记住这一点，因为我总是认为那一刻本该是你生命的最后一刻，却成了别人的娱乐。这并没有让我感到痛苦。它只是改变了我对为什么的看法，我非得取悦所有人吗？所以那件事我只是想，好吧，我明白了，公平地说，如果事情就是这样，我以为这不仅仅是那样。但你必须时刻首先照顾好自己。所以有点，是吗？
No, not that. I don't think in terms of that. I just think in terms of sometimes we get kind of caught up in the idea that it's more than just entertainment or something like that. The expectation on human beings is lowered a little bit when stuff like that happens. We see it, you see somebody fall in the subway in New York and everybody pulls out their phone. Put your fucking phone down. Yeah.
不，不是那样。我不是那样想的。我只是认为有时我们被困在一种想法中，认为这不仅仅是娱乐或类似的东西。当那种事情发生时，对人类的期望稍微降低了一点。我们看到了，你看到有人在纽约地铁里摔倒，每个人都掏出手机。把你的该死手机放下。是的。
And lend a hand. Jason and I got in a taxi accident in New York like a year and a half ago on 23rd Street and we got on the side and we're like, geez, and the cab's smoking. We look over and there's a kid right next to us filming us. Really? Yeah. We're like, hey, man. Can you use that phone to call the cops, please?
伸出援手。杰森和我大约一年半前在纽约23街发生了一起出租车事故，我们侧翻了，我们想，天哪，出租车在冒烟。我们看过去，旁边有个孩子在拍我们。真的？是的。我们说，嘿，伙计。你能用那个手机打个电话报警吗，拜托？
Yeah. That was the thing. Call the cops. Call the ambulance. I actually told this story. I got hit by a car on 57th Street like four years ago and he was doing at least 40 and I was looking the wrong way and he spun me out and I landed on my feet, but I kind of spun.
是的。就是那件事。报警。叫救护车。我实际上讲过这个故事。大约四年前我在57街被车撞了，他至少开了40迈，我当时看错了方向，他把我撞得转了一圈，我双脚着地，但我转了一下。
I came so close to death because he just caught, he just sort of sideswiped me and I got to the other side and I was so fucking rattled right at Park Avenue and I get over the other side and I'm like, Jesus Christ, I almost fucking died. Look at this guy. He's looking at me and I go, did you see that? And he goes, yeah. Can I get a picture? I went, Jesus, I almost fucking died, asshole.
我离死亡如此之近，因为他只是，他只是侧面擦到了我，我到了另一边，我在公园大道上被撞得该死地晕头转向，我到了另一边，我想，天哪，我差点就该死地死了。看这个家伙。他看着我，我说，你看到了吗？他说，是的。我能拍张照吗？我说，天哪，我差点就该死地死了，混蛋。
But you know, George, you bring up something. Did you take the picture though? That's what's important. I did take the picture because he seemed like a genuine fan, but George, I remember one time, I don't know if you remember this. The first time we really met, I was with John Krasinski, we went for sushi and you guys were working on leatherheads at the time and there's a great thing, I gave you a ride back to your house and this struck me and I loved it.
但你知道，乔治，你提到了某件事。你拍那张照片了吗？那才是重要的。我确实拍了那张照片，因为他看起来像个真正的粉丝，但乔治，我记得有一次，我不确定你是否记得。我们真正见面的第一次，我和约翰·卡拉辛斯基在一起，我们去吃寿司，你们当时正在拍《皮头》，有一件很棒的事，我开车送你回家，这让我印象深刻，我很喜欢。
And you're directing a movie and you're George Clooney and you've done all this great stuff and you're doing more great stuff and I was really, I really, and kind of Sean mentioned it before too, you know, you've done, and you talked about it, you've done all these pilots, you know, I did like seven pilots, I had 50 canceled shows, I did every variation that you could of canceled before it went, got fired off a show before it got picked up, like just all of it. And so I always like, in a lot of ways, and I'm almost embarrassed to say this because I hate giving up any power, but you were often in a lot of ways, very much a North Star for
你正在导演一部电影，你是乔治·克鲁尼，你做了所有这些伟大的事情，你还在做更多伟大的事情，我真的，我真的，肖恩之前也提到了，你知道，你做了，你谈到了，你做了所有这些试播集，你知道，我做了大约七个试播集，我有50个被取消的节目，我经历了你能想到的所有被取消的变体，在节目被选中之前就被解雇了，就像所有这些。所以我总是，在很多方面，我甚至不好意思说出来，因为我讨厌放弃任何权力，但你在很多方面，确实在很大程度上是我的北极星。
me in a lot of ways. And so it was really cool and we drive back to your house and we get to the gate and I forget what it was, but you, and I'm driving and I said, what's the code? And by the way, the gate looked like it was at a, you know, just at a goat rodeo, it could have fallen off and you could walk around it and you go like, and you go like, it's like one, the code's one, two, three, four, no, you know, what are you out of your mind? And then we drive up to the house and we walk out, we get out and you go, it's okay, door's open.
所以这真的很酷，我们开车回你家，我们到了大门口，我忘了是什么了，但是你，我在开车，我说，密码是什么？顺便说一句，那个大门看起来就像是在一个，你知道，就在一个山羊竞技场，它可能掉下来，你可以绕过它，你说，你说，就像一，密码是一、二、三、四，不，你知道，你疯了吗？然后我们开车到房子，我们走出来，我们下车，你说，没关系，门开着。
And I go, and I said to you, I go, are you crazy? You got the fucking world, look at your gate is one, two, three, four, your door's open. You go, yeah, I'm just not going to be a prisoner. Yeah. I'm like, it floored me. It floored me. And also I was like, that's fucking rad. Good for you.
我说，我对你说，我说，你疯了吗？你拥有该死的世界，看你的大门是一、二、三、四，你的门开着。你说，是的，我只是不想成为囚犯。是的。我当时想，它震撼了我。它震撼了我。而且我也觉得，那太该死地酷了。为你高兴。
Well, I now have a better code with kids. Yeah, of course, of course, of course, but that was, you know, 15 years ago. And by the way, I don't live there. At the risk of embarrassing you, you really have very consistently sort of represented a way in which to do this, this fame and fortune thing that I think gives actors a good name. I will just say, you have always been so effortless with your, with your just keeping it kind of real. It's never, it's never waned.
嗯，我现在有了孩子，密码更好了。是的，当然，当然，当然，但那是，你知道，15年前的事了。顺便说一句，我不住在那里。冒着让你尴尬的风险，你确实非常一致地代表了一种处理这种名利的方式，我认为这为演员赢得了好名声。我只想说，你一直都那么毫不费力地，那么真实地保持着自我。它从未，从未减弱。
Even the responsibility of using your platform to speak up every once in a while about things that you think are left or right of good. And with that specifically, are you, and I don't, I don't want to get you into a political place that you're not comfortable with or any of us are comfortable with in today's, today's climate, but, but given today's climate, do you find yourself thinking twice or three times now before you talk about certain things that might really bug you as opposed to how you may have felt five, 10 years ago? No, I think it's the exact opposite.
即使是利用你的平台偶尔为那些你认为是非对错的事情发声的责任。具体来说，你，我不想让你进入一个你不舒服的政治领域，或者我们今天在当今气候下都不舒服的领域，但是，考虑到当今的气候，你现在在谈论某些可能真正困扰你的事情之前，是否会三思而后行，而不是像你五、十年前的感觉那样？不，我认为恰恰相反。
You know, I think that, you know, there's a line in the film I wrote, Good Night and Good Luck that Murrow says, because this is no time for, for people who have opinions to be silent. You know, there was a period of time a couple of years ago where the executive branch, the legislative branch and the judicial branch were all kind of dropping the ball in a way. And in some ways, you need the fourth estate to pick up. You need the news organizations and things like that to pick up the slack. And they did.
你知道，我认为，你知道，我写的电影《晚安，好运》里有一句台词，默罗说的，因为现在不是那些有观点的人保持沉默的时候。你知道，几年前有一段时间，行政部门、立法部门和司法部门都在某种程度上掉链子了。在某些方面，你需要第四权力来接手。你需要新闻机构之类的东西来弥补空缺。他们做到了。
They did a pretty good job of holding people's feet to the fire, and the judicial branch actually came around eventually. But along those lines, you know, you need people, you got to be out there, if you believe it, you know, and listen, you can be John Boyd and believe that Trump's, you know, a God and save those things, fair enough, you know, have at it, you know, do your thing. But I do believe that this is a time where if you have, you know, I'm not going to lose my right of citizenship because I'm, you know, I've reached a place of success in my career. And you know, I grew up in the 60s, man, you know, we were, if you weren't talking about
他们做得很好，让人们承担责任，司法部门最终也确实转变了。但沿着这些思路，你知道，你需要人们，你必须站出来，如果你相信它，你知道，听着，你可以是约翰·博伊德，相信特朗普是，你知道，上帝，并说那些话，公平地说，你知道，随你去吧，你知道，做你的事。但我确实相信这是一个时代，如果你有，你知道，我不会因为我，你知道，我在职业生涯中达到了成功的地步，就失去我的公民权利。而且你知道，我在60年代长大，伙计，你知道，我们，如果你不谈论
social issues, if it was the Vietnam War, the civil rights movement, the women's rights movement or any of those things, you know, there was something wrong with you. And so I grew up with the idea that it's your responsibility to pick fights. You know, what else? What good is this sort of megaphone if you don't get to, you know, try to amplify certain things. And I find it more interesting now. Speaking to that, because you're part of not in our watch project and the tons of foundations
社会问题，无论是越南战争、民权运动、妇女权利运动还是任何这些事情，你知道，你就有问题。所以我是在这种想法下长大的，即挑起争端是你的责任。你知道，还有什么？如果你不能尝试放大某些事情，这种扩音器有什么用？我现在觉得它更有趣了。说到这一点，因为你是“不看我们”项目的成员，还有大量的基金会
and organizations. Is there one you're most proud of that you pay most attention to that you're most involved? Well, Mal and I have, we have this foundation, the Clinton Foundation, and we're doing some pretty amazing stuff. Like we're right now monitoring the Navalny trial in Russia. It's a fascinating moment. We have trial watchers in about 30 different countries. Countries are using the court system to commit the same crimes that they normally would do
和组织。有没有一个你最引以为傲的，你最关注的，你参与最多的？嗯，阿迈勒和我，我们有这个基金会，克林顿基金会，我们正在做一些相当了不起的事情。比如我们现在正在俄罗斯监测纳瓦尔尼的审判。这是一个迷人的时刻。我们在大约30个不同的国家有审判观察员。各国正在利用法院系统来犯下他们通常会犯的罪行
without the court system. So they're basically saying, well, the judge found them guilty when the judge is also the prosecutor. Right, right. And this will be, you know, finding guys guilty for being gay in Nigeria and, you know, all kinds of just insane stuff. So we're putting trial watchers in there. We're trying to, because this is all happening in the darkness.
而不需要法院系统。所以他们基本上是在说，嗯，法官判他们有罪，而法官同时也是检察官。对，对。这将会是，你知道，在尼日利亚判处同性恋者有罪，你知道，各种疯狂的事情。所以我们正在那里安排审判观察员。我们正在尝试，因为这一切都在黑暗中发生。
And so we're trying to be able to set up and create a method and a way to monitor and keep and hold these people responsible. It takes time. You have to build enough cases up to basically create a justice index and where those countries stand on those. Well, that's, that's, that's so rad. And by the way, I just, I just found yesterday, I just found Sean guilty of being gay here in America.
所以我们正在尝试建立和创造一种方法来监测并保持，并让这些人负责。这需要时间。你必须建立足够的案例来基本上创建一个司法指数，以及那些国家在这些方面的立场。嗯，那，那，那太酷了。顺便说一句，我刚刚，我昨天刚发现，我刚发现肖恩在美国被判有同性恋罪。
I just can't, I just came out and just got a trial coming up soon. Yeah. Just verdict just came in. What happened to, so do you guys know, I know that publicly they, they say they don't know where Navalny went, but specifically, do you guys have an idea of where he went? Or, and they said, you know, he's not going to be treated any differently. Where he's being captured, man. They're sending him to a work camp now, which is a pretty dangerous spot to go.
我刚出柜，很快就要受审了。是的。判决刚下来。发生了什么，所以你们知道吗，我知道公开场合他们说他们不知道纳瓦尔尼去了哪里，但具体来说，你们有主意他去了哪里吗？或者，他们说，你知道，他不会受到任何不同的对待。他被抓了，伙计。他们现在把他送到劳改营，那是一个去处相当危险的地方。
But I don't think anyone knows which one. Maybe they do. I haven't, haven't checked. You know, we, we also have one of the parts of our foundation, something that had started before Amal and I actually met was I think called the Sentry. And we're doing with that, you know, the idea of following these, you know, war criminals. I used to do all this stuff. We had a satellite that we rented and we would shine it over the border of the Sudan and
但我认为没人知道是哪一个。也许他们知道。我还没，还没查。你知道，我们，我们基金会的一部分，在阿迈勒和我真正见面之前就开始的东西，我想叫“哨兵”。我们正在做的是，你知道，追踪这些，你知道，战犯的想法。我过去常做所有这些事。我们租了一颗卫星，我们会把它照在苏丹边境上，
be able to follow troop movements and, and mass graves and, and, you know, we had really really good success at being able to point out these atrocities, but nobody did anything about them. Right. Nothing. You'd have it on the front page of the New York Times and nothing would happen. And we always say these things like never again, but it's always again and always happens. And so what became really clear was you can't make these bad guys be good, but they don't
能够追踪部队调动和乱葬坑，而且，你知道，我们在指出这些暴行方面取得了非常非常好的成功，但没有人对它们做任何事。对。什么都没有。你会把它放在《纽约时报》的头版，什么都不会发生。我们总是说像“永不再犯”这样的话，但它总是再次发生，总是发生。所以变得非常清楚的是，你不能让这些坏人变好，但他们
give a shit. But there's tons of people who are doing business with these bad guys who you can because they want to put on a goddamn tux and go to an award show or go to a banquet because it'll be, you know, for a while, it was the banks who were ignoring these guys who were spending, you know, they're not doing it in Sudanese pounds. They were doing it in pounds and dollars and euros and they're banking in our Western banks. So you go to them and say, well, these guys are laundering about $400 million in your
根本不在乎。但有很多人在和这些坏人做生意，你可以，因为他们想穿上该死的燕尾服去参加颁奖典礼或参加宴会，因为那会，你知道，有一段时间，是银行在无视这些家伙，他们花着，你知道，他们不是用苏丹镑做的。他们用英镑、美元和欧元，他们在我们的西方银行存钱。所以你去找他们说，嗯，这些家伙在你们的银行洗钱大约4亿美元
bank and the banks turned around said, give us all the information. We give it to, you know, to the U.S. government mostly to try and freeze their assets of the Treasury Department. We even did it with the Trump Treasury Department. We gave them tons of information and they froze assets and it's the same thing. So it's really fun to be able to, you know, go to people who really think that they're the good guys and say, well, you're not looking that hard. So we're going to tell you this and I'm going to hold a press conference tomorrow and either
银行转过身说，把所有信息给我们。我们把它给，你知道，主要是给美国政府，试图冻结财政部的资产。我们甚至对特朗普的财政部也这么做了。我们给了他们大量信息，他们冻结了资产，道理是一样的。所以能够，你知道，去找那些真正认为自己是好人的人，说，嗯，你们看得不够仔细。所以我们要告诉你们这个，我明天要开个新闻发布会，要么
you're going to say, yeah, we have nothing to do with these guys or I'm going to tell them you're complicit and once you do that, you shut down the avenues for these people to spend their money. And that's a big way. You know, we had a good fun time with the salt and the brineye on that as well and it was really effective. That's so right. And on that level, you're not, you're not just using your, your platform and your voice.
你们说，是的，我们和这些人没关系，要么我就告诉他们你们是同谋，一旦你这么做了，你就切断了这些人花钱的途径。这是一个很大的方式。你知道，我们在盐和布里内上也玩得很开心，而且非常有效。那太酷了。在那个层面上，你不仅仅是在利用你的平台和你的声音。
You're actually involved in a real way and obviously, you know, follow the money. But by hurting them there, you're really affecting change in a real way. That's super fun. Well, I'll tell you, it's a funny thing. Here's the, here's the deal. All the things we did, we were talking about earlier, whether it makes the cut to your podcast or all the things we were talking about earlier, the pranks that you play, right? The way, when you're playing a prank, you're basically trying to set people up to react
你实际上是以一种真实的方式参与其中，显然，你知道，跟着钱走。但通过在那里伤害他们，你真的在以一种真实的方式影响变革。那超级有趣。嗯，我告诉你，这是一件有趣的事。这是，这是交易。我们做的所有事情，我们刚才谈到的，无论它是否进入你的播客，或者我们刚才谈到的所有事情，你玩的恶作剧，对吧？当你在玩恶作剧时，你基本上是在试图设置人们去反应
the way you want and to get them to do what you want to fuck with them. Right? Well, that's what you're doing with world leaders in the same way with people who are, you know, war criminals in the same way, you're going, okay, well, I'm going to shed on a paper plate. These exactly show a paper plate and stick it on the thing. But that's the truth because that's sort of the, the, the mentality with this is, yeah, I have a completely different question that we're going to end on and this is from my
你想要的方式，并让他们做你想让他们做的事来戏弄他们。对吧？嗯，这就是你对世界领导人所做的，同样的方式，对那些是，你知道，战犯的人，同样的方式，你正在做，好吧，我要在纸盘子上拉屎。这些完全展示了一个纸盘子，把它贴在东西上。但那是事实，因为这就是，那种心态，是的，我有一个完全不同的问题，我们要以这个问题结束，这是来自我的
brain, George. Okay. If you could, out of the entire cast, if you could have, out of the entire cast of Oceans 11, besides Julia Roberts slept with somebody who would have been, you got Pitt, you got Damon. Please say Brad Pitt. Please say Brad Pitt. Brad Pitt.
大脑，乔治。好的。如果你能，在整个演员阵容中，如果你能，在《十一罗汉》的整个演员阵容中，除了朱莉娅·罗伯茨，和某人睡过，会是谁，你有皮特，你有达蒙。请说布拉德·皮特。请说布拉德·皮特。布拉德·皮特。
This is another one from Tracy. This is Brad Pitt. Yeah. Come on. Yeah. That's a no brainer. Same. Same.
这是特雷西的另一个问题。这是布拉德·皮特。是的。来吧。是的。那是不假思索的。一样。一样。
I mean, come on. You guys feel the same. All right. He's pretty, pretty boy Pitt. I'll tell you something. We went to, we went to for Oceans 12, we went to Europe to do the premiere and we ride in, we, you know, Jerry Wine Troubles does everything, so he's got us on a yacht and we're going up to Monaco first on our way to Cannes to open Oceans 12 because Oceans 12 is a perfect Cannes
我是说，来吧。你们感觉一样。好吧。他是漂亮的皮特。我告诉你们一件事。我们去了，我们去了《十二罗汉》，我们去了欧洲做首映，我们骑着，我们，你知道，杰瑞·温特劳布做了一切，所以他让我们上了游艇，我们先去摩纳哥，在去戛纳的路上，为了开启《十二罗汉》，因为《十二罗汉》是一部完美的戛纳
film. Right? That's exactly what you want to take to Cannes. So we're getting there, we take off and we're in Monaco, there's the Grand Prix. We have our names on the back of a Jaguar race car, right? And while we're riding there, the car rolls over and catches on fire and our names are in flames, you know, above the thing. Oh my God.
电影。对吧？那正是你想带去戛纳的东西。所以我们到了那里，我们起飞了，我们在摩纳哥，有大奖赛。我们的名字在捷豹赛车的后面，对吧？当我们骑在那里时，车翻了，着火了，我们的名字在火焰中，你知道，在东西上方。天哪。
We get there and it's Pitt and Cheetle and Damon and I and we're all in this boat and there's surrounded by 50 paparazzi pontoon boats, you know, everywhere just trying to get your picture. And Brad's like, I am going to go up on the top and jump off of this thing. It's like six stories high and we're like, okay, let's do it. We go up there to jump and Brad takes off his shirt and it's like something Michelangelo has carved out of marble, right? It's just like ridiculous.
我们到了那里，是皮特、奇德尔、达蒙和我，我们都在这条船上，周围有50艘狗仔队的浮筒船，你知道，到处都是，只是想拍你的照片。布拉德说，我要去上面，从这东西上跳下去。它有六层楼高，我们说，好吧，让我们做吧。我们上去跳，布拉德脱掉了他的衬衫，就像米开朗基罗用大理石雕刻出来的东西，对吧？简直太荒谬了。
And then Matt goes, wham! And he pulls off his shirt, which is, yeah, like something that Pillsbury Doughboy cut out of him. And I'm standing there and I'm looking and I go, what's wrong with you, man? I'll take your shirt off right now, you put it on all these people. Unless you wanted a comfortable chest to sleep on, then you go for Matt, you know? It's at the pillow you can punch. You know, Matt will get in like shape.
然后马特说，砰！他脱掉了他的衬衫，那是，是的，就像皮尔斯伯里生面团男孩从他身上切下来的一样。我站在那里，我看着，我说，你怎么了，伙计？我现在就脱掉你的衬衫，你把它穿在所有人身上。除非你想要一个舒服的胸部睡觉，那你就选马特，你知道？那是你可以打的枕头。你知道，马特会进入那种状态。
I mean, he'll be like, you know, Jason Bourne, you know? Off season, you know, it's wine and beer. Let's stay warm. Yeah. It's like. I remember, I was at a Bon Iver concert, Jason, you'll love this, and we were talking to Justin Vernon and we come and Brad came in and he goes, hey, man, I really loved your show that you did for Netflix.
我是说，他会像，你知道，杰森·伯恩，你知道？淡季，你知道，是葡萄酒和啤酒。让我们保持温暖。是的。就像。我记得，我在一个好伊维尔音乐会上，杰森，你会喜欢这个的，我们正在和贾斯汀·弗农交谈，我们来了，布拉德进来了，他说，嘿，伙计，我真的很喜欢你在Netflix上做的那个节目。
I said, oh, thanks. And we went out the door and I slid down the wall and I cried, oh my God, he's so gorgeous. Now wait a second. If he's validating Bon Iver, I'm in because he did that for me with Radiohead. I had no idea Radiohead was way back when and I still am addicted to Radiohead because he stamped it. You know what? So I'm on Bon Iver now.
我说，哦，谢谢。我们走出门口，我顺着墙滑下去，我哭了，天哪，他太华丽了。现在等一下。如果他在验证好伊维尔，我加入了，因为他为我做了那个，关于电台司令。我不知道电台司令是很久以前的事了，我仍然沉迷于电台司令，因为他盖了章。你知道吗？所以我现在在好伊维尔上。
I love them. I also said to him, I said, you know, Brad, you know what movie is aged really well? Benjamin Button. That's so dumb. Incredible. Incredible. He liked it. We were shooting, we were shooting Oceans 12 in Italy, Brad, you know, we'd been doing
我爱他们。我还对他说，我说，你知道，布拉德，你知道哪部电影老得很好吗？本杰明·巴顿。那太蠢了。不可思议。不可思议。他喜欢它。我们正在拍摄，我们正在意大利拍摄《十二罗汉》，布拉德，你知道，我们一直在做
shit to each other, Frank's to each other. And Brad took out, put posters on telephone poles all around my hometown in Como, Laleo, this little town that said, you know, George Clooney is here shooting now and he only wants to be referred to by his character named Danny Ocean and don't look him in the eye. Just like, in the newspaper, he gets like, il divo. And I'm like, fuck, fuck. I'm like, I'm going to fuck this guy up. And so he had a Prius and I, I, I went to one of those shops that you go to that has
对彼此做坏事，对彼此的恶作剧。布拉德拿出来，在我的家乡科莫，拉莱奥，这个小镇的电线杆上贴了海报，上面写着，你知道，乔治·克鲁尼现在在这里拍摄，他只想被称为他的角色名字丹尼·奥申，不要看他的眼睛。就像，在报纸上，他得到了像，il divo。我当时想，该死，该死。我当时想，我要搞死这个家伙。所以他有一辆普锐斯，我，我，我去了那些你去的商店，有
bumper stickers and license plate things and I found a bumper sticker that was in the shape of a pot plant that said, fuck cops. There's no way you don't get pulled over with that on the back of your car. It lasted one day, he came over and he goes, dude, that was, that was cold. Has there been any like garbage about you or fake news about you that has made you laugh? Like, that is so crazy. It always makes us laugh. I mean, I send them to, you know, it's funny because it's, I'm every day, literally every
保险杠贴纸和车牌东西，我发现了一个保险杠贴纸，是盆栽植物形状的，上面写着，去死吧警察。你不可能不因为那个贴在你的车后面而被拦下。它只持续了一天，他过来，他说，伙计，那，那太冷了。有没有关于你的垃圾或者关于你的假新闻让你笑过？比如，那太疯狂了。它总是让我们笑。我是说，我把它们发给，你知道，这很有趣，因为它是，我每天，字面上每一
single day I'll get, you know, life and style or national inquire is going to run this story. You have an hour to respond and it's always just like, you know, it just makes us laugh. I was just right back to like stand my pose and just say, suck it. Because it's just like, you know, what's your response? Suck it. You know, if you're going to be childish, I can be childish. I love it. I don't know.
天我都会得到，你知道，生活与风格或者国家询问报要运行这个故事。你有时间回应，它总是就像，你知道，它只是让我们笑。我只是回信说，坚持我的姿势，只是说，去死吧。因为这只是，你知道，你的回应是什么？去死吧。你知道，如果你要孩子气，我也可以孩子气。我喜欢它。我不知道。
There's no, the idea that I'd ever see something that even had a grain of truth would be funny. You handle it all with so much grace. You always have, you always will keep leading it for all of us, please. And I know you don't do a lot of press, my friend, and you're very picky. So thank you for being on our dumb dumb show. Well, listen, I want to say this, you guys, and this is absolutely the truth. I have grown this habit of listening to podcasts. I like to listen to them when I get in bed at night.
没有，我曾经看到过哪怕有一点点真实的东西会很有趣的想法。你以如此优雅的方式处理这一切。你一直都是，你永远会继续为我们所有人引领它，拜托。我知道你不做很多媒体，我的朋友，而且你非常挑剔。所以谢谢你来到我们这个愚蠢的节目。嗯，听着，我想说这个，你们，这是绝对的事实。我已经养成了听播客的习惯。我喜欢在晚上上床睡觉时听它们。
Some of them I use to help me sleep. Not that that's a bad thing. I'm not talking about yours. I listen to like American history tellers and stuff because I like history ones and I like to learn stuff. And I got turned on to yours a while back and I have to say, I can't play it at night when I want to go to sleep because I sit up and listen to it and laugh through the whole thing. You guys made me laugh.
有些我用来帮助我睡觉。不是说那是一件坏事。我不是在说你们的。我听像美国历史讲述者之类的，因为我喜欢历史类的，我喜欢学习东西。我很久以前就被你们的吸引了，我不得不说，我不能在晚上想睡觉时播放它，因为我坐起来听它，笑得整个过程。你们让我笑了。
Well, you made our dough. I've known all of you and I'm a giant fan, but man, you guys together are hysterical. Thank you, George. Thank you, buddy. Likewise, man. It's fun. Really, really appreciate you coming on, man. Yeah, total honor.
嗯，你赚了我们的钱。我认识你们所有人，我是个超级粉丝，但伙计，你们在一起太歇斯底里了。谢谢你，乔治。谢谢你，伙计。同样，伙计。很有趣。真的，真的很感谢你来，伙计。是的，完全的荣幸。
It's good to talk to you. Very nice. All right. Enjoy the rest of your day, pal. Okay. Bye, guys. See you soon, buddy. Bye.
和你交谈很好。非常好。好的。享受你剩下的一天，伙计。好的。再见，伙计们。很快见，伙计。再见。
See you, George. Sean, what a holy shit. Sean, you got real moves. You know I love George Clooney. Who doesn't? Yeah, it's true. GC in the house. Well, if you had a heads up that it was going to be George, would you, would you have worn
再见，乔治。肖恩，真是该死。肖恩，你真的有动作。你知道我爱乔治·克鲁尼。谁不爱呢？是的，这是真的。GC在房子里。嗯，如果你有一个预告说会是乔治，你会，你会穿
anything different? Would you have done anything different with your hair? Do you think you would have moisturized a little bit more, something like that? Well, why? Do I not look? You look a little dry. Your black shirt is disappearing into your black background there. I feel like you probably would have, you would have gone for something.
什么不同的吗？你会对你的头发做任何不同的事情吗？你认为你会多涂一点保湿霜，之类的吗？嗯，为什么？我看起来不吗？你看起来有点干。你的黑色衬衫正在消失在你那里的黑色背景中。我觉得你可能本来会，你会去选一些。
By the way, normally I'd hit back with something else, you know, really in trying to take you out. You're still a little stunned. But I'm really, I'm so, I'm so worried and my self-esteem is so shaky around George that that's, so I got to ask you, are you being serious? Because I can't take it. No, I'm not being serious. Because I might cry.
顺便说一句，通常我会用别的东西回击，你知道，真的试图把你干掉。你还是有点震惊。但我真的很，我真的很担心，我的自尊心在乔治周围太脆弱了，所以，所以我得问你，你是认真的吗？因为我受不了。不，我不是认真的。因为我可能会哭。
You did very, very well. And so did Sean. We, I think that was awesome. Yeah. I read a lot of stuff that he, there's tons of stuff I wanted to get to that I couldn't, but I, I read a lot of stuff before he came on and he's just, I love that it was like exactly as I, as I, as I, I've always kind of known him to be and I, and I assume our audience always hopes him to be, which is like this perfect balance of funny and smart
你做得非常，非常好。肖恩也是。我们，我认为那太棒了。是的。我读了很多他，有很多我想达到但我没能达到的东西，但我，我读了很多他在来之前的东西，他只是，我喜欢它是完全像我，像我，像我，我一直认为他是一个，我，我假设我们的观众总是希望他是，也就是像这种有趣和聪明的完美平衡
and, and, and a listener and a speaker and you know, I mean, it's just, he's, he's, he's he's a perfect man. The other thing that I love, which, and it was kind of, was evident in that story that I told about when I went over to his house with, with Krasinski and we go for, Krasinski goes sushi. I mean, Clooney just texted me, let's go get some sushi. I almost said sushi just texted me. So we go over and then he says, and then George says, Hey, can you give me a ride home?
而且，而且，他既是倾听者又是演说者，你知道，我的意思是，他简直，他，他，他，他是一个完美的人。我喜欢的另一件事，这在刚才我讲的那个故事里很明显，就是我和克拉辛斯基去他家的时候，克拉辛斯基说去吃寿司。我的意思是，克鲁尼刚给我发短信说去吃点寿司。我差点说成寿司刚给我发短信。所以我们去了，然后他说，乔治说，嘿，能载我回家吗？
And I'm like, yeah, no problem. And so I give him a ride home and he was so cool and he was so down to earth and he was so the same. He's the same guy that you see when he's on Carson or, or whatever, or tonight show, or that you see when you meet him 10 years ago, and he's the same guy when you see him and we'd see him. Sometimes he comes, we've seen him over at Jans a couple of times or whatever and just always consistently like, Oh yeah, he's just down to earth and a good guy.
我说，没问题。于是我载他回家，他真的很酷，很脚踏实地，一直都没变。他和你平时在卡森秀或者今夜秀上看到的他，或者你十年前见到他时，他都是同一个人。我们有时会在简氏餐厅看到他，他总是始终如一，哦，是的，他就是那么脚踏实地，是个好人。
And he spends so much of his free time, not just advocating for people, but actually getting his hands in there and getting his hands dirty and doing it and it's, it's bloody impressive. Isn't it? He walks the walk and talks to talk. Yeah. Yeah. Also, Sean, I like that you brought up. I don't know if it's going to be a normal segment because Jason and I have to talk about
他花了很多业余时间，不仅是为人们奔走呼吁，而且是亲力亲为，实实在在地去做，这真是太令人印象深刻了，不是吗？他言出必行。是的，是的。还有，肖恩，我很高兴你提到了这一点。我不知道这是否会成为一个常规环节，因为杰森和我必须讨论一下
this with the question from Tracy. Isn't that a great idea? And it can only be for my guests, like, right? So you guys don't have to worry about it, but I thought it'd be funny. Just so that I know going forward, is it, is it T-R-A-C-E-Y or just a Y or is it an I? Is it an I dotted with a heart? With a heart?
特蕾西提出的这个问题。这不是个好主意吗？这只能针对我的嘉宾，对吧？所以你们不用担心，但我认为这会很有趣。为了以后方便，我想问一下，是T-R-A-C-E-Y，还是只有一个Y，或者有个I？那个I上面是不是点了一个心形？心形的？
With a heart is an I? I mean, I don't want to be disrespectful. I just want to know what we're dealing with. Wisconsin, Wisconsin gets a lot. If we do this tour that we've talked about so many times, if we ever do a tour, we'd have to go to Wisconsin. Absolutely. I don't even know if anybody would want to see us on tour.
带心形的I吗？我的意思是，我不想不尊重人。我只是想知道具体情况。威斯康星，威斯康星有很多听众。如果我们真的进行了我们讨论过很多次的巡演，如果我们要巡演，我们肯定得去威斯康星。当然。我甚至不知道是否有人想看我们的巡演。
I'd like to hear from, from Madison to see if they would like to welcome us there. And, and what would be, what would be the other cities? Let's, let's, if any, does he, do people even know how to get a hold of us? Do they vote on cities for a tour? If we get like, like let's say like the five most sort of requests, we'll go to those five cities. Yes. We'll come to your city.
我想听听麦迪逊那边的人怎么说，看看他们是否欢迎我们去。还有，还有其他城市会是哪些？让我们，让我们，如果有人，他们知道怎么联系我们吗？他们会投票选出巡演城市吗？如果我们得到，比如，最受欢迎的五个城市，我们就去那五个城市。是的。我们会去你的城市。
But you got to let us know that you want us first because we're really insecure. You need to go first and invite us instead of us assuming you want to see us. Tell us why you, not why you're worthy, but why we're worthy of coming to your city. I love that. It's a great idea. Guys, this has been a, a, a, an embarrassment of riches as far as ideas going today. Today. Today's episode has a lot of God.
但你得先让我们知道你想要我们去，因为我们真的很没安全感。你需要先主动邀请我们，而不是让我们自作多情地以为你想见我们。告诉我们为什么你，不是为什么你值得，而是为什么我们值得去你的城市。我喜欢这个主意。这真是个好点子。伙计们，今天关于点子的讨论真是收获颇丰。今天，今天的节目内容很丰富，天哪。
And if we do a tour also, can we stay with you? Yeah. Let us know. That's a deal breaker. Do you have like a guest house or is it a, is it a blow up? We'll need pictures. So. Yeah.
如果我们去巡演，我们能住在你家吗？是的。告诉我们。这是个关键条件。你们有客房吗，还是那种充气床？我们需要照片。所以。是的。
We'll probably need pictures. And then we'd also need to be able to send stuff that we like, like I like half and half just to make sure. Probably a car. Right. Use of a car. A car for, which is fine. We could share, um, but we're coming to your town and we're coming to your house.
我们可能需要照片。然后我们还需要能够寄送我们喜欢的东西，比如我喜欢半脱脂牛奶，只是为了确认一下。可能还需要一辆车，对吧？使用一辆车。一辆车，这没问题。我们可以共用，嗯，但我们要去你的城镇，去你的家里。
We're coming to your house. Let us know if you want us there and we'll, the house that we send out everything and, and we'll, we'll be there. Also should we do a tour at all? Should actually for real, should we do a tour? I think we should. I think it'd be fun. I don't know.
我们要去你的家里。如果你想让我们去，就告诉我们，我们会把一切都安排好，然后我们就会出现在那里。另外，我们到底该不该巡演？真的，我们应该巡演吗？我觉得应该。我觉得会很有趣。我不知道。
People would want us. I'm available. Let's see. I'd like to finally see you guys while we're talking to each other. Yeah. Right. That would be actually, you know, a lot of podcasts do, do tours. Is that right?
人们会想要我们去吗？我有空。让我们看看。我希望能最终在面对面交谈时见到你们。是的，对吧？那实际上，你知道，很多播客都会做巡演。是这样吗？
Yeah. Well, why not us? Let's, uh, let's put it in the pipe and smoke it. Okay. Well, we'll see people. Maybe they don't want it. People are like, then we don't want to see you. Okay.
是的。嗯，为什么我们不行呢？让我们，嗯，让我们把它提上日程吧。好吧，我们看看大家怎么说。也许他们不想要。人们可能会说，我们不想见你们。好吧。
Um, all right. Well, um, so, uh, there's a bunch of different kinds of bicycles, right? There's the, the one with the three wheel and what's the one with the two wheels called? Um, bye. So, uh, uh, all right. Oh, yeah. Bye. Bye.
嗯，好吧，嗯，所以，嗯，自行车有很多种，对吧？有那种三个轮子的，那两个轮子的叫什么来着？嗯，自行车。所以，嗯，嗯，好吧。哦，是的。自行车。自行车。
Bye. Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Oh, so stupid. Smart.
自行车！自行车！自行车！自行车！自行车！哦，太蠢了。聪明。
Right. Smart. Right. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
对。聪明。对。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。